一応ヴィパッサナー瞑想の方法
まあ説明になりました
またあの略して申し上げると
まあ禅定っていうのは
まあ一つ この現実的な日常生活からの離れですからね
で 離れていく まあそれで楽かもしれませんし
問題解決したことになりません
生きることから離れたんだからといって
不安も消えたわけでもないんですね
そうすると この究極的なこの非想非非想情というね
禅定を得ても それは一応終わったことにして
また普通日常な生活の中で日常に生きてみようとすると
日常的に で ごく普通にご飯食べたり
歩いたり 人と話したり
寝たり立ったりとかね
まあそちらで言っているのは
まあごく普通に生活しているんだということ
わざと座っていようと
わざと立っていようと
そんなことでもない 人間というのは
まあ立ったり座ったり歩いたり
人と話したり また横になったり
また何か食べたり いろんなことをしたりしますね
24時間で そのごく普通の当たり前の生き方の中でお釈迦様は厳密にヴィパッサナーの実践方法をこっちのこの経典で教えてあったんですね
どういうことかというと
心にこのアビッジャーとヴィアーパーダという
その 2つの精神的な病気ですね
その 2つは まあ怒りと欲なんですけど
それはもう正真正銘の精神的な病気なんですね
それは全ての人には一応あります
一応ではなくて 必ずあります
アビッジャーというのは余計な非論理的な
具体的 具体性は全くない
実現することはもうほとんど不可能な欲
どうにもならん欲 怒りの場合も
誰かに何か騙されて怒ったというような
この具体性ある怒りではないんです
誰かに騙されてお金取られてもカンカン怒っているんだと
それはすごい具体的で合理的で
もう何か解決する方法あるんですね
怒っていいわけじゃないんですが
まあそれでも何か解決する方法あるんですよ
で そういう怒りはまあどうにもならんというかね
世の中で生きている場合は人と喧嘩しなくちゃいけないし
いろいろ事にはなるんですけど
そんなものではなくて
お釈迦様が言ってるのは
この精神的に もう欲と同じく
もうどうにもならん もう非現実的で
具体性は全くなくて 非論理的で
ただ怒りが生まれてくる
ガチャガチャガチャガチャ怒りのことばっかり考えると
で その 2つ それはヴィアーパーダと言うんですね
まあヴィアーパーダの
まあ私の訳は間違ってると思ってるかもしれませんだけど
まあテキストで訳はまあ一応注釈書というかね
まあ訳はまあ他人をな
殺そう 害与えよとかね
で 死んでしまえという風な怒りやと
それしか説明は書いてないんです
ですから まあそれで十分だともなればそれで十分ですけど
私の個人的な説明は まあそれは非現実的な
非論理的な 精神的な病気になる種なんですね
そういう怒り ですから
この頭の中でごちゃごちゃいろんな人のことやらもう嫌やら
あれが嫌や これは嫌やとか
天気も嫌やとかね この世界も嫌とか
いろんなことをもう限りなくもう怒りの妄想が入ってくるんですね
その論理的な怒りではなく
なんとか解決する方法ある怒りではなく
このものすごい余計な強烈な怒り
そのアビッジャーとヴィアーパーダ
その 2つから綺麗に徹底的に心をガードする
ただそれだけ 徹底的にガードする
それでその普通に生きてみます
普通に仕事をしたり 人と話をしたり
掃除洗濯をしたり 寝たり立ったり
いろんなことをして生活をしますけど
24時間厳密に心の中にこのアビッジャーとヴィアーパーダだけ入らないように
厳密に心をガードしてみる
そこをやってみると ものすごいそれはヴィパッサナー瞑想で
だからトイレに行っても
横になっても おせんべい食べていても
誰かと喋っていたとしても
それだけは気をつける
そこでその人間どうなるかというと
厳密な論理的な具体的な人間になるんですよ
何にもとらわれなくなっちゃうんです
それで心にやっと余裕が出て
このもう無常の発見というかね
無我の発見というか そういうのができるんですね
だから中途半端ないい加減な瞑想というわけじゃないんです
これはものすごいもう24時間体制でやらなくちゃいけない
そこでお釈迦様またテーマ変える
テーマ変えて また別な説明をします
パン
チャコーイメーアーナンダカーマグナカトメーパンチャチャックヴィンニェヤールーパ・イッターカンターマナーパ・ピヨルーパ・カーマルーパ・サンヒターラジャニー
ヤー・ソータヴィンニェヤー・サッダーガーナヴィンニェヤー・ガンダジーヴァーヴィンニェヤー・ラサーカーヤヴィンニェヤー・ポッダッバー・イッターカンターマナー
パ・ピヨルーパ・カーマルーパ・サンヒターラジャニーヤー
パンチャイメー パンチャコーイメー
まあコーっていうのはちょっとしたこの日本の和みたいな感じで
それほど意味あるわけじゃないし
まあこれらは五つ アーナンダよ
これら五つありますと
これらって何ですか？カーマグナ
カーマグナというものは五つあるんだよと
あのカーマっていうのは欲のことなんですね
だからグナの訳なんですね
難しいのは まあグナっていうのは
大体このものの特色を説明するとき使う一つの言葉で
このいいところはグナというんですね
悪いところはアグナと呼ぶんですけどね
ですから もののいいところを強調してみる場合は
まあそういう風に使ってますけども
[紙の音]辞書で徳やら功徳と
名欲 だからこの言語学者はカーマのグナと思ってますけど
いわゆるカーマの いわゆる欲の徳
欲の情操というかね っていうふうに思ってますけどね
で それでずっとみんな訳して注釈して頑張ってますから
私の訳はそのまま捨てられるだろうと思いますけどね
で まあでも経典内容を見ると
お釈迦様はまあまあ欲の情操というふうな意味で使ってるわけじゃないんです
欲の情操と言えば形容詞なんですよ
だからまあ物ではないんです
人の背が高いというと
背が高いということは物ではありません
人がものであって その人の特色
背が高いということなんです
だから別に背が高いというものは
別にその人から離すことはできませんしね
だからまあアジェクティブとしてね
形容詞として使うものっていうのは
そのものについてるもので一体なんですね
いい人やと言ったら じゃあその人のいいところをちょっと持ってきてと
ちょっと調べたいんだよと言ったってね
それはできません いい人がいるんだけど
じゃあその人を連れてきてという言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
一緒だから その形容詞はね
だからカーマグナっていうのは
まあまあ 何なのかね だからこの辞書で名欲と書いてますけどね
まあ適当な言葉やと思いますけど
で 一応お釈迦様はカーマグナと言ったっても
このカーマっていうのは欲
これは心に生まれる感情
カーマは一応主観的なものなんです
この主観的にカーマを引き起こす
主観的に欲を引き起こす
外の世界にある対象 品物について語るとき使う言葉なんです
そこで私の心にカーマを欲を引き起こすんだから
そちらにそれなりの特色があるんですね
だからそれは一つの徳として
情操として見ているんです
それは 5つあるんだよと
まあ正しいというか 理解できる
この意訳はカーマを引き起こす対象なんです
対象が 5つあるんだよと
品物は 5つあるんだよということなんです
この品物のいい側面を見て言ってるだけのことで
例えば美味しい食べ物ありますと言ったら
その食べ物のいい側面を言ってるだけで
それは体に悪いかもしれませんでしょうしね
それは言わないで これがすごく美味しいんですよと
美味しい食べ物ですよと
そうやって食べ物にしても
美味しいという特色あるし
食べたらものすごいコレステロールがあって
もう年取った人にとってはもう体に悪いかもしれませんし
あまりにもまあ何でしたっけ
砂糖がありすぎて 糖尿病の人にはすごい悪いかもしれませんしね
まあそれは規律ではなくて
まあこれは美味しい食べ物ですよという
だからその場合は このもののすべての特色を言うわけ言えませんだから
ただ一つ言ってるだけでは
一応この理屈でこちらカーマグナと読むんですね
で だからグナと言ったっても形容詞であって
カーマと言ったっても主観的な心の感情であって
その 2つ繋げて客観的な対象を語ってるんだから
これ言語学者が訳できなくなっちゃうんですね
先生 カーマの特徴 いい特徴とか悪い特徴ある？ ん？ カーマの特徴っていうか
特別なキャラクターっていう
それがいいキャラクターもあれば悪いキャラクターもありますかって聞いてる
どんなものについてもありますからね
この世の中に それはもうディマックとか一生懸命説明したように
ものを見る場合は あの
何でしたっけ イススぐらいの立場で見るんだよと
当初短所で執着 執着から離れること
そういう風にもいろいろな高めるでしょうね
どんなものにもあることですね
で こちらではカーマっていうのは主観的な欲のことです
グナっていうのは特色であって
いわゆる徳 良い長所であってね
その 2つ繋げても 言語学的には意味は通らない
ですから そんなに難しいことではない
単なる五欲のことを言ってるんです
それでカテメーパンチェ
このイススの五欲は何なのかと
チャックウィンネーヤ・ルーパ
目で認識するルーパ だからルーパと言えば
また辞書でいろいろ意味が出てきますけど
こちらできちんと意味を制限していますね
目で認識するものはルーパと言うんだよと
目を通して認識するもの
すべてルーパなんですね
それでイッダ そこからは翻訳は合っていると思いますけど
好ましい カンタというのはなんか楽しいと訳していますね
マナーパ 喜ばしい ピエルーパは愛しい
カームサンヒタ 欲を伴った
魅力的な  魅力的な ラジャニーヤは魅力的な
そこで目に見えるものがありますよ
すごく好ましくて 楽しくて
魅力的で もうすごく なんて言いますか
引っ張られやすくてね
すぐそこに惹かれやすいという
目に見えるものもあるんだよ
だから目に見えるものはいっぱいありますよ
いっぱいあるんだけど
それどんなものにも 私たちはもう楽しくてたまらなくて
もうどうにもならない状態になるわけじゃないんです
その目に見えるもう多数の無数のルーパの中で
そのその個人にとってはあるルーパが
まあ楽しくて愛しくてたまらないという
まあルーパがあるんではないかと
それにカーマグナと言うんです
見えるものはすべてカーマグナではないんです
何か見たところでもう楽しくて
もうもう愛しくて もうもう魅力があって
もうどうにもならん状態
だからそれ見たら心の中で欲を起こしてしまうんですね
起きてしまうんですね
現れてしまうんです  そういうルールがありますよ
そこでこのパーリ語として言えば
まあイッターっていうのは
なんかそれ見るとすごい機嫌が良くなるんだというね
意味でイッターと言うんですよ
カンターっていうのは
このなんて美しいですかという
この芸術的にこのというかね
なんかなんと美しいですかと
なんて綺麗ですかという風な
このソフトな感じなんですけど
そういう心の状態はカンターというんですね
で 物につけるんですけどね
この絵のこの線なんかは
なんて柔らかくて微妙に綺麗で美しいでしょうとかね
そういうふうに感じることをカンターというんです
マナーパっていうのは
この個人の好み あ これがもう私の好みやと
この絵は自分の気に入りやという
このことをマナーパという言葉で意味するんですね
ピエルーパっていうのは
まあ単なる綺麗な絵という意味なんですね
カーマウパサンヒタっていうのは
どうも見るともうどうにもならん
あれ見るともうなんて言いますか
病みつきになるよという状態は
いわゆるカーマが生まれるんだよと
欲が生まれるんだよと
ラジャニーヤっていうのはもう染めてしまう
ラジャっていうのはもう色のことでね
汚れのことで もうそれで染めてしまうとという意味なんですね
それから次にソータヴィンニャヤサッダ
ソータ 耳で認識する音がある
この世の中でものすごい無数に音があるんだけど
その中である一部の音を聞くと
まあどうにもならん状態になるんですね
美しくて綺麗で もうもうもう聞きたくて聞きたくてたまらなくて
もう粘りついてしまう
もう自分を引っ張られてしまうというふうな音
で 3番目はガーナヴィンニャヤガンダ
鼻で嗅ぐ香りですね で
香りといったら日本語でちょっともうややこしいんですけど smell
なんですよ それはもうもう鼻につくものは全部smellと言うんですけど
それはgood smellbad smellという 2つあるでしょうし
だから臭いものもあるし
すごい香りのいいものもあるし
だから香りという言葉はあんまり良くないんですけど
香りは大体はまあ気に入ってるものに言うだけだからね
だから気に入るかいらないかということではなくて
匂いというものをこの世の中にあるんです
匂いなんですね だから無数にこの世の中で匂いあるんだけど
その中である一部の匂いがもう快楽で快楽で
もう心は混乱してしまっちゃうというか
もう引き寄せて魅力が感じて
魅力的で欲が生まれてくる
すべての匂い そういうわけじゃないんです
だから ある人が病みつきになる匂いが
他の人には全くもう嫌な匂いかもしれませんしね
それを言ってるわけじゃない
この匂い自体は世界で絶対的に美しくて魅力的で
生命の心を引き寄せますよってそんなこと言ってるわけじゃないです
そんなこと言ったら嘘を言うところでしょうに
だから個人にとっては
もう無数の匂いの中で
ある匂いに際しては もう心が喜びも愛も欲もいろいろ未練も感じてしまう
その匂いということ それから同じことジウハヴィンニャヤラサ
舌で認識する味ですね
味の場合もどんなものも味持ってますよ
味は無数にありますし
そのいろんなものの味があるんですけど
まあある味について我々はすごい魅力感じる自分の好みで楽しくてたまらん味があると
で カーヤヴィンニャヤポッタッパ
カーヤヴィンニャヤっていうのは
この体で感じるもの すべてポッタッバというんですね
触というんですね 触れるもの
体に触れなきゃわからないんですよ
体に触れるもの 空気でも体に触れないとあるとはわからないんですね
ですから 体に触れるものっていうのはいくらでもあるんだけど
その中で一部はもう楽しくてたまらないと
もっともっと触れてほしいという気持ちが生まれてくる
触もあります そのその 1つの触
5つのこの対象というか
認識から見れば認識対象
それはカーマグナと言うんですね
だから世の中 目に体に触れる
色触何でしたっけ 色声香味触という
その五つなんですけど
それ言っちゃうとあまりにも普遍的で
あまりにも普遍的なんです
あまりにもアビダルマ的なんですね
で こちらはそうじゃなくて
もう体に五つは触れる
その中で無数に物が触れる
その中でこの一部があるんだよと
自分の心はもう未練感じる
愛しいと感じる どうにもならんと感じてしまう
色声香味触 それで終わり
見即と五つあるんだよと
だからこの 色声ですね
香味触という 五感が自分に対して未練感じるならば
自分の好みであるならば
自分にとってはもう綺麗で
もう好きで好きでたまらんだったら
その五つにカーマグナと言うんです
だから私のカーマグナは他の人のカーマグナではありません
でもどんな人にもカーマグナは確実にあります
だから この心のところからお話をしているんですよ
心の煩悩という そこのそこから話をしているんです
別に外の世界と戦おうということではなくてね
で そこはまず理解しておく
5つありますよと理解しておいて
次にこういうことをその比丘はするんですね
イメ
コーアナンダパンチカーマグナヤッタビクナアビカンタンサカンチッタンパッチャウェッキタッバンアッティヌコーメーイメーシュパンチャスカーマグネーシュアンニ
ャタラスミンワーアンニャタラスミンワーアーヤタネウッパジャティチェッサソーサムダーチャーローティ
そこでビクナアビカンタン
いつもいつもフリークエン
Frequently Frequently
なんです うん あ 常に たまたまではないんです
ビッカンタンというのはもうもう英語で言えばfrequently
いつもでももう常にやらなくちゃいけない
サカンチッタン 自分の心をパッチャウェッキダッバン
観察するんです もうパッチャウェッキってっていうのはもう
すごくいい ものすごい仏教の世界ではこの大事な言葉なんです
ものすごく使ってます
で これはサンスクリット語で言えばプリティアヴェクシャという言葉二つ
このパーリ語になってパッチャウェッキになってますけどね
で もういわゆるちょっと遡ってみるというかね
振り返ってみるというかね
アヴェクシャっていうのは見るという何ですけど
それは観察するという意味なんですね
目で見る意味というよりもね
観察する で ちょっと振り返って観察する
振り返るというんですかね
ちょっと遡って 顧みる
パッチャウェッキ 僕 俗的な日本語で言えば反省ということなんですね
反省っていうのは起きた出来事について再び評価してみることなんです
日本語の反省なんとか分かりませんですけど
一応まあ我々その言葉を使う場合は
まあいわゆるまあちょっとリバリュエーションなんとかやってみるんですね
こういうこういうことをしましたけど
まあこういうこういう過程でどんなものでしょうか
どの風になったんでしょうかとか
もう結果もできてるんだから
この過程といいところ
まずかったところ 失敗したところ
うまくいったところ そこら辺はもう一応観察するんですね
それは一般的に言う反省ですね
後悔とは違います だからものすごい知識的な仕事なんです
すごい役に立つ仕事なんです
パッチャウェッキっていうのはそうやってこの顧みることなんですね
だからその比丘はいつもいつも常に自分の心を顧みることするんです
観察するんです 何を観察するかというと
アッティヌコメイメーすパンチャすカームグネーす
イメーすパンチャすカームグネーす
この五つのカーマグラに対しては
カーマグラにおいては
私に何かあるんでしょうかと
アッティっていうのは動詞ですから
アンニャタラスミンは
ちょっと待って そうそう
アーヤテネウッパッジョティチェータソサムダーチャロ
すごい難しい厳密なんですけど
こちらはね  もし比丘の観察して
なんかしてないみたい
どれかにおいて あるいはどれかのところにおいて座りている
私には心の活動が動きが働き
活動ですね はいはい  これら五種の妙薬の内のいずれかにおいて
どこかにおいて あるいはどこかのところに生まれている
生じていると  チェータソサムダーチャロという言葉がありますね
チェータソというのは思考のことで
まあ知識 意志 意志 意志なんですね
サムダーチャラっていうのは
この もう何かプラクティスするというか
何か実行するとかね 実践するという
何か行うことをサムダーチャラなんですね
それであの普通人々と言葉交わすことにもサムダーチャラと言うんですけど
挨拶交わすことにもパーリ語でサムダーチャラと言うんですけどね
いわゆる普通に行う出来事という意味なんですね
サムダーチャラだけ辞書を引いてみると
まあね 挨拶 会話って意味なんです
でもその意味でこの経典が使っているわけじゃないんです
すごい専門用語として使ってるんですね
だからその場合は原語で分析しなくては
サンとウッとチャラというチャラティという動詞
組み合わせて サンっていうのは一緒にウっていうのは出てくるという
チャラっていうのは行うこと
何かに一緒に何か出来事が起こるでしょうかという
だからもっと簡単に訳すれば
反応を起こしてるんでしょうかと
何かに反応を起こすんでしょうか？という訳なんです
だから反応するということは同時に反応しますよ
何か起こると それとそれと一緒にこちらが反応を起こしちゃうんですね
サマーチャーラといって
この場合は心理学的な言葉で心の反応
だからチェータ・ソー・サモーチャーラと言うんです
何かに心の反応が起きるだろう
起こるでしょうかと 起きたでしょうかと
だからどこかどこか どこかどこかっていうのは 5つの場所があるんだから
自分の体に この体に場所が 5つありまして
そのどこかで反応でもしたんでしょうかと
心が とチェックするんです
それにチェックするんです
それもこの厳密なヴィパッサナー瞑想はぴったし一つの項目で言っていることが
ワンセットで完全に語っているんです
これだけ実行したっても
もう完璧なヴィパッサナー悟りの瞑想なんです
だから こういう語り方っていうのはブッダ以外できないんですね
だから前に説明したのも完璧なヴィパッサナー瞑想なんです
それと全くアプローチが変わって
全く別な見方で また同じ瞑想法を完全に語ってしまいます
どちらにせよ だって 24時間体制でやらなくちゃあかんことで
中途半端にできるものでもないんです
だからヴィパッサナーにしても
そうやってお釈迦様のあのすごい知恵でいろいろやり方を教えるんですね
結局道は同じなんですよ
この方法で瞑想したら別に成長で
あの方法で瞑想すれば別な成長というまるっきりありえないんです
どちらがやったってもいいんです
なんでそうやって多数に方法を語るかというと
人の個人の理解の世界なんですね
だから私にとって何が理解しやすいかということ
例えば前の場合は 別に修行とか何とかとか
なんか別にどうってことはない
もしかするとだいたい世間向けかもしれません
仕事をしながら 子供の面倒を見ながら
もう社会のことやら何でもやりながら
心はアヴィッジャーとヴィーアーパダから守ると
だからすごい大変な厳しい修行なんですよ
筋肉的な厳しさはまるっきりもないんだけど
心についてはすごい厳しい修行なんですね
でも 在家の方々にも 特に遠い昔
ブッダの時代では女性の方々も
それからその後でもみんな女性の人々というのはなかなか出家できないしね
で 素晴らしい日本の女性陣たちが私にね
私はものすごい女性差別しているんだとか言ってはいるんだけど
私はあまりにも怖くて返事出せてないんです
まあそういうことには
向こうの頭 あまりにも良すぎて
私は 相手にならないんです
ですから まあ勝負にならないんだだからね
じゃあ黙ってようと で
私が知っている限りは
女性には出家は無理ですよ
子供はいるわ いろいろ問題はあるわ
もうあらゆる束縛あるんですよ
それは女性差別かどうか分かりませんだけど
まあもう体もそれなりに
そんなに男みたいにね
山の中やらそんな生活できるわけでもないし
子供がいたりするとね
まあじゃああっち行けという感じにはなりませんしね
で 結構生物学的には男性よりは自由がないんですけどね
まあそれが女性差別というならば
まあどうぞ勝手に もしかするとそんなこと言ってる男たちがね
子供でも産んでいる可能性あるかもしれませんね
それ聞きたいんですよ
あるいは女だったらね
あんた誰か女性認識して妊娠させたことでもありますかとかね
男だったらあんた子供でも産んだことがありますかとかね
だからまあそういうことだから
やっぱり女性の生き方っていうのはね
もうかなりいろいろありますよ
だからもうはい 出家しますよと言ったってもね
そうできるわけじゃないし
例えば歳 の女の子とかね
歳の女の子とかね もう徹底的に仏教気に入っちゃって
じゃあ出家してやるぞと思っても
これ両親がね 出してくれるんですかね
出ていて 出ていてもいいんですよと
今の時代にしたっても
親がなかなか独立させないでしょうに
二十歳ぐらいにならないまでは
それは差別でしょうかと聞きたいんですけどね
じゃなくても本当に危険でしょうしね
もう身の安全もないでしょうし
ですから まあそういう問題はあるんですね
ですから まあ例えばもうお釈迦様の場合
もういましたから 若い女の子たちがちゃんと悟って出家してないんですよ
普通にもう親の面倒見ながら
家の仕事を手伝いながら
たまたまみんなと喧嘩しながら
わがまま言いながら普通生活しています
でもちゃんと悟っているんです
で どういう風にやっているかという
こういうその方々は やっぱり日常生活をしながら
厳密に自分の心を持ってみる
ですから まあそれはもう一つの方法で
まあ次にやるのはもう一つの
今説明したのはもう一つの方法で
それでその人は普通に生きているんだけど
目に何が映るか分からない
耳にどんな音が入るか分からない
口にどんな味が入るか分からない
体にどんなものを触れるか分からない
その中で一部ありますよ
未練を感じる 心を引っ張れる
自分では美しい 好みや気に入ったと
愛しいと感じるものがあるんですよ
そこでその比丘がいつでもそれでどこかで私の心が反応したんでしょうか
反応したんでしょうかとチェックするんですよ
だから心が反応したっていうことは
引っ張られたっていうことなんですよ
例えばいきなりなんか綺麗な
例えばもう木がもういっぱい花が咲いているのを見て
すごいと思った瞬間にも反応を起こしているでしょうね
ああ なんて綺麗やと思ったのはもう反応を起こしています
それをチェックするんです
反応を起こしたかと どこかどこかでっていうのは
体で反応を起こしたか
耳で反応を起こしたか
目で反応を起こしたか
鼻で反応を起こしたか
舌で反応を起こしたかとか
これもすごい人に見られない修行なんですよ
やってみるとどうですかね
ご飯食べる時でも 心は全く反応を起こさないようにとかね
それできれば立派だと思いますけどね
それが本物の仏教の修行なんですよ
ただ 何か特別に何かやったんだから
特別な服を着て 特別な食べ物を食べて
特別な生き方をして 世俗世間から全く別な何か行事式だり儀式やって
それで私はこれぐらい修行したんだぞとかね
ミャンマーにも行きました
スリランカにもカンボジアにも行きました
アメリカのなんとか瞑想道場に行きましたとかね
よく宣伝しているそれでだから何よということなんですけど
どこに行かなくたっても修行できる人にはできるし
できる人は自慢は絶対しないし
修行しているのに自慢したらそれで終わりだから
修行は それも反応だから
だから私はこの間に書いたんですよ
だからもう悟った人は言わないんだと
って言ったってもわかるわけないでしょうに
この人々に だからに足す二はいくらですかと言ったら
もう十回ぐらい指を重ねてもう四かなとか
聞く人にじゃあ相対性論とかね
教えてくれと どんな総額ですかとかね
教えられますかね だからあの質問もまあ一応あの
まあ何でしたっけ この早川さんと一緒に書いたんで
早川さんに言ったら 書く前にこいつらバカにしてやるぞと
そのまままんまともう網にネズミ引っかかるようにまんまと引っかかってるんですね
だからバカを見ると だからあのまだ反応する返事出したいところ誰かがいるんですけどね
このバカも やっぱり失礼でしょうしね
だからまあそこら辺でということで
それでもちゃんと私は答えを書いているんですけど
読めないと思います 答えは書いてます
読めない 理解できない
それを知っています 別に難しい日本語で書いてるわけでもない
ここは普通の日常のみんな育ってる日本語で書いてます
だからまあ上がってこいと
天皇陛下に会いたいと言ったって
お前のうちに来るわけじゃないんだと
それなりの功績を上げて
日本の社会で認めれば
向こうからは呼びますよと
でないと自分の家でもアパートでいて
もういくら踏ん張ったってもね
それはもう世界違いますからね
じゃあとにかくこのだからこの修行の世界っていうのは
この本物の修行の世界
そういう修行の世界なんです
表面的にはまるっきり見えません
普通にもう例えば月になってくる
そこら辺はまあ歩くかもしれませんよ
もうすごい花も見えるかもしれませんし
みんな踊ってるように見えるかもしれませんだけど
本人がまあ何のことなく心の中で反応を起こさないようにチェックする
こういうの表面的に見えますかね
もし変な修行だったら
いっぱい花咲いてるところで歩く場合は
でっかい帽子をかぶって上見えないようにと下を見て歩くかも
そうすると立派な行者ですよとか
世間は言う なんて立派な行者ですか
これほど美しいところあるのに
頭開けて見ようともしない
その代わりに わずかでも見えたら困ると思って顔を隠しているんだと
すごい帽子で で みんなは褒めますけど
あれは修行ですかね 心はどうですかね
心は弱いんだからそんなことやってるでしょうに
そんなことやっ一向に心が強くなりますかね
見ないだけで 聞かないだけで
だから仏教は徹底的にそれに反対するんです
だったら生まれつき目が見えない人はもうすごい煩悩がなくて良かったと
だったら生まれつき 例えばね
脳細胞全く機能しない
もうただのまあなんとかなんとかで生まれたらもう悟ってるんだよと
そんなことになるんだと
生まれた赤ちゃんはもうとっくに悟ってるんだよって
それをはっきりお釈迦様おっしゃったんです
あんたの話から見ると
生まれてる赤ちゃんがとっくに悟ってるんだよと
煩悩というところは世の中何なのかとわかってないんだと
その赤ちゃんが そんなもんじゃないんだよ
だからこちらにあるのは正真正銘のお釈迦様の生の言葉の修行の説明なんですね
それは後でカッコつけるようにいろいろ方法になってしまっただけのことで
こちらでは何もカッコつけることはなくて
その比丘はいつでもいつでももう世の中で人間にとってはもういろいろ人間にとっては
だから私には好みの色があって
好みの音があってとか
それはどんな個人にもある
自分がこの自分の足を引っ張られるところについてはすごいチェックを入れてみる
観察を入れてみる 省みることはしてしまうという
サッチャー
ナーンダ・ビク・パッチェッカ・マノ・エーワン・パジャーナーティ・アッティコ・メー・イメー・パンチャ・スカマ・グネー・アニャタラス・ミン・ワー・アニャタ
ラス・ミン・ワー・ヤタネー・ウッパジティ・テーソ・サムーダー・チャーローティ
そこで完成したところで
やっぱりあっちこっちで心が反応したんだぞと
この比丘が出家者が発見する
省みるを実践したところで
あ こういうところで こういうところで
こういうところで 自分の心がパッと反応しちゃったそうととわかると
エーワン・サンタン・エータン・アーナンダ・ビク・エーワン・パジャーナーティ
反応したんだよとわかったらこのことをやるんですね
ヨーコー・メー・パンチャス・カーマ・グネス・チャンダ・ラーガ・ソー・アッパ・ヒー・ノー・テー
それだ ヨーコー・メー・パンチャス・カーマ・グネス
この五つのカーマ・グネスについて
私のチャンダ・ラーガがまだまだあるのとわかるんですね
それ その智慧の一つなんですね
別に反応を起こして悪いってことじゃなくて
省みたところで反応を起こしちゃったなと発見するんですね
発見したらなんで反応を起こしたかというと
まだまだチャンダ・ラーガがあるんだ
私には 私の心にチャンダ・ラーガがある
チャンダ・ラーガっていうのは心の欲そのものの意味なんです
だから外に咲く花が悪いわけじゃないんです
その花に対して私の目がもうやっぱり引っ張られるんですよ
その引っ張られるのは
自己の心にチャンダ・ラーガがあるんだからなんです
チャンダ・ラーガがなかったならば引っ張らないんですね
チャンダっていうのはまあ喜ぶという意味で
ラーガっていうのは欲ということで
心の中にまだまだ欲があるんだと
心の中にその特色があるんだと
この対象に対して喜びを感じちゃうという
喜んでみようではないかという
心の中にその特色がある
それは欲なの それが欲であって
外の世界は欲ではありませんと
と仏教ははっきりしているんです
外の世界 この俗世間は決して悪いわけでもないんです
決してもう欲の欲の塊で
人はなかなか悟れないんだと
この欲 世の中のせいで
ある中国人がシンガポー人なんでよく言うんで
私に この世の中であまりにも誘惑が多すぎて
なかなか瞑想なんかできない
できないんだと だからもうまあ笑うしかない
お前が弱いんじゃないか
まあ英語だから淡々と言えますから
ディス・イズ・ユア・フォールトと言っちゃえば
すぐまあ本人が分かりましたけどね
言った人が 世の中のせいにするんじゃないよと
君はしっかりしなさいよと
だからまあよく分かってくれたんですけど
だからそういう風に   先生がおっしゃったの
夜 夜話でおっしゃった心の接着剤みたいなもんですっておっしゃったの
チャンダ・ラーガ  それはもうなんですけどね
まあそんなに区別なく
だって全部ワンセットだからね
チャンダ・ラーガっていうのは
やっぱりチャンダ・ラーガは欲のことなんですね
ランディラーガ  それも同じなんです
チャントなんてのは同義語なんですね
イティ タッタ サンパジャーノホーティ
そこでそのことについてもサンパジャ―のいわゆるサティヤ
そういうことやと理解しておく
別に何とかしようではなくて
すごく正直に 素直に 厳密に
正直に 私の心にまだまだチャンドラーがあるんだそうということで
チャンドラーについてもちょっと認識を確認をしておく
サチェーパナーナンダ
ビックー パッチェッカマーナオー エヴァン パジャナーティ ナッティ コー メー イメー ス パンチャス カー
マ グネー ス アニャタラス ミンワ アニャタラス ミンワー ユティネー ウッパジーティー サムダーチャー
そこでまた観察すると
振り返ってみると なかなか反応してないんだなと
この間あれ見たんだけど
全然反応しなかったと
あの人が歌っていたんだけど
私の前に別に反応してなかったよとかってわかるでしょう
例えば 自分の前で人がすごい美しい声で歌っている
自分が最近の時はすごい好みの歌でしたかもしれません
感動した歌かもしれません
ただ聞いているだけで全然心反応しないねとかね
わかるで その場合は 感動しないと
心反応しないというふうにわかったならば
ヨー コー メー パンチャス カーマ グネー ス チャンドラーゴー ソー メー パヒーノーティ
このパンチャカーマグネについては
このカーマグネ5つについては私のチャンドラーがもうないねとわかるんですよ
だからその確認作業でわかることであって
そこで何についてもチャンドラーが生まれなかったら
もう悟っているんです
無理をしなくても 無理をしなくたっても
自然 だからあくまでも自然で生きてみないと
本物の悟りは得られないんです
あくまでも自然で徹底的な掃除機に生きてみないと
本物の悟りっていうのは出てこない
だからもうただやってやろうという気持ちとことを私は時々申し上げますけど
その場合はこの怠けをもうちょっとなんとかしなさいというチャレンジしなさいという意味であって
でもなんかじゃあやってやるんではないかというふうに
この自我で始めたら それで掃除機でなくなっちゃうんですね
だから言葉っていうのはえらい難しいことで
使うのもね で 掃除機に 24時間気をつけて生きてみる
そうするとさんさんもう欲が生まれたこと
心が反応したことがさんさんわかってくる
わかってくるたびにそれも確認していく
また反応起こしたらまたそれも確認しておく
これで気をつけて気をつけている途中でいろいろ知恵が開発するし
もうやがて無常なんかを発見したら
まあ欲が起こるところじゃないということになっちゃうんです
そうするとまた自然体で前と同じくごく普通に生きているんで
でも心はあり得ないものに反応はしない
それでいくら観察したって
観察に反応していない
反応していない 反応していないことになるんです
反応しないんだと自分の心はわかったら
もうそこはもうはっきりした悟りなんですね
だからもう一人の人が
このあんたがという悟りっていうのは
この あの なんか強引に
あの 引き起こす あの 練習体験みたいな主観的な幻覚ではないかと
で 私は一つすごい長い返事書いちゃったんだけど
文章を直すところで全部消えちゃったんです
で それでまあもうだったらもうちょっと曖昧でまあまあで書こうかなと
まあまあのところ書いたんで
最初の文章すごい良かったんですけどね
一発で書いたものをね
そこで書いたのはね もう徹底的に書いたんです
あんた方はね まあそういう練習体験なんかはね
した人が知ってますかとかね
その人の脳細胞をもうチェックしたことがあるんですかと
で そういう人を掴まっと捕まってみて
その人の人格と悟った人の人格っていうのは経典に散々書いてるんだから
合ってるかないか調べてください
その場合は全く同じだと
ブッダと同じだとわかったら
もうそれはやっぱり練習体験から強引に引き起こす練習体験
これ脳細胞の物質の変化によって
もうよく知ってるつもりで書いてるんですけどね
だから文章を見ただけで
どこまで読んでどこまで知ってる人かということも丸っきり見えちゃいますから
もう私だと返事出せないんですよ
みんな自分を隠しているつもりでしょうし
こちらは隠れませんけど
だから悟りに就いている人はもう気持ちわかります
何者かと だから本人が私の答えで随分納得
まあ単なるウィンドウショッピングだから
なんか人のことをけなしてみたいでしょう
あんたがそうじゃ でも私ほど偉くないんだという気持ちなんですよ
だから まあその人にはそれなりの返事出せばいいんです
だからその人は随分納得しました
私の言葉に 私はもうただのそこら辺のウィンドウショッピングの人で
これ値段いくら？これ 1,500万円ですけど
ああそう で 帰るだけのことで
ポケット見たら 1,000円もないかもしれませんしね
だから一旦値段聞いたらね
まあたとえウィンドウショッピングであろうともね
まあこれは値段を見てあげるのは礼儀だから
まあそうと帰るだけで
だからこのそうやって幻覚的な練習体験とか
なんとそれは私は書いた
それは幻覚ですと でも漢字は変えたんです
それ 2番目の答えで 1番目の答えはもうものすごい
もうものすごいキツい
徹底的に学問的な言葉をなめるんだったら
こちらも徹底的にやってやる
それもうすごい書いたんだけど
もうなんかまあなんか打ち間違いあって
これ直そうと ESC キーを押したところですべてエスケープになっちゃって
いつでもそういうことで
ESC キーでプログラムの
あの 停止させてくれるんだから
それ簡単にやっちゃいますけど
これあんまり使ってはいけないんです
あのキーは 左一番上にやるキーは
で 確定して手で消した
あのバックスペースで消した方がもうすごい安全なんです
で まあ仮に文章を編集
仮にあるプログラム組みた機能しているんですよ
だから ESC キーでそのプログラム自体が完全にストップしちゃうんで
だからまあその時はこのプログラムの段階によって全て消える場合もあるし
それだけ消える場合もあります
だからそれすり替え忘れちゃうと
もう大変なんですね まあ失敗は知ってますけど
いつでもやります それでも
なんか分からない だから前に書いたのはこの精神的な病気だと
それはね 何か変な何か幻覚起こったっていうことは病気だと
だから悟りは精神的な病気ではありませんと
修行のは最初からもうあらゆる幻覚
あらゆる あの 固定概念っていうのをね
徹底的にもう壊すことだから
全く違うんだよと それは主観的な幻覚だと知りたければ
修行する人々に頭にいろんな器具をつけて修行させなくちゃいけないんだと
真面目な修行者っていうのはあんた方に認めてほしくてね
宣伝はしませんと それはインチキ超能力者たちがテレビに出てきて
簡単に騙せる科学者に自分の能力を見せて完璧に騙すんだと
そんな商売じゃないんだと
金のために修行する人は修行しないんだと
金のために修行したって悟るわけないでしょうと
だから一向にあんた方にわからないんだと
こんなことは 真面目な人にとっても
体中あらゆる電極つけちゃうと気持ち悪くて修行できますかね
その場合 きちんと瞑想なんかできるわけないでしょう
それでいつ悟るかもわからないんだから
まだ 何年つけてみるんですか？だからもうありえない
どうにもどうでもいい話なんですけどね
ただくだらんことを言う
それで前の文章はまあ聞いた方がいいなと思いますけどね
一応 だから幻覚ではなくてね
はっきりした経験で幻覚ですよと
だからそこらここら辺読んでみたっても
なんか変な神秘的な体験でないということね
これは智慧の開発であって
智慧の完成性完成であって
だから徹底的に省みるという修行してみるんですよ
心を省みる 振り返ってみる
どんな調子か どんな調子か
どんな調子か そうするともうチャンドラーガがあったあったあったあったあったあった
あの場合はあった この場合はなかった
あの場合はあった この場合はなかったとか
それはずっとあってやって
それでどんどん物事を見えてくるんですよ
その物事を見える過程をお釈迦様はだいたいは言わないんですよ
そこはもう経典で 1箇所 2箇所でしかないんです
で それをまた別な枠で延々と語っています
実践の修行とはつなげておかない
これ別な説法にしているんです
だから全然問題はないんですけどね
で だからこの場合は預流果ですかね
一来果ですか？不還果ですか？これも判断できません
だからそう簡単じゃないんです
本人しかわからない だからどの程度チャンドラーガが低くなったかっていうことね
これ必ず切れていくんですよ
どちらも程度があるんですよ
完璧に切れちゃったというと
もしかすると阿那含 不還果かもしれませんし
もしかすると阿羅漢かもしれませんしね
だからそれはもうその本人とお釈迦様しか知らないんですよ
この智慧のね 開発のレベルと
そういうところは で まあもう一皮深くいきます
またテーマ変えます パンチャコーイメーアーナンダウパーダーナカンダヤッタビックー
ウデアッビャーヌパッサナーヴィハアタッバン
イテ
ィルーパングイティルーパッササンブドーイティルーパッサアッタガモーイティヴェーダナーイティヴェーダナーヤサンブドーイティヴェーダナーヤアッタガモーイテ
ィサンニャーイティサンカーラーイティヴィンニャーナーイティヴィンニャーナッササンブドーイティヴィンニャーナッサアッタガモーティ
タッサイメーすパンチャスウパーダーナカンダース
ウデアッビャーヌパッシーノーヴィーラトー
ヨーパンチャスウパーダーナカンダース
アスミマーノーソーパヒーヤティ
パンチャコーイメーアーナンダウパーダーナカンダ
カンダっていうのはもう山ということで
まあすごい大きい塊という意味なんですね
スカンダ 普通サンスクリット語だったらスカンダと言えば
まあボディという意味なんですね
体という身体という意味なんですね
で まあまだいろいろ意味あるけど
現代的にはあまり使ってないんだから
そういう意味であってもね
だからシステムという組織
システムという意味にも使える言葉なんですけど
現代ヒンディー語やらスリランカ語やら
インドの各語の中では
スカンダはあんまりシステム
組織ということには使ってないんですね
ですから もうそれしょうがない
そういう意味はありますけどね
使ってないんです まあですから
まあ私たちの理解のためには
まあ 5つの組織がある
あるいは塊がある まあ5つの品物があるということで
これ体のことなんですよ 5
つの機能でもよろしいし
組織でもよろしいし システムでもまあそれでもよろしいし
まあそれで体ができてますね
それだからウパーダーナスカンダと言うんですね
その 5つに分けたのは
あの科学的に分けたわけでもなく
いろいろ学問的に分けたんではなくて
分けた尺度ウパーダーナという尺度なんです
執着する 何に執着するんだなと見たら
5つを分けてみたんです
だからものは分類する場合は何か尺度が必要なんです
この場合はウパーダーナという尺度で分類してみたら
5つ見つかったということで
ウパーダーナというのは執着
だからこの五蘊ですけどね
スカンダは五蘊のことで五蘊がありますよと
五取蘊ありますよと 五取蘊というのは執着する組織が5つありますと
1番目は ヤッタビクナウデアッビャーヌパッシーナーヴィハアタッバン
その 5つに際してはウデアとビャエ
生と滅を見なさいと その 5つが現れて消えて現れて消えて現れて消えていくのではないかと
その生滅の過程を見なさいと
5つの ここで 5つの1番目はルーパでしょ
ルーパっていうのは体のこと
物体こと 色 色受蘊 体という執着の塊
体そのもの その場合は物体的な体なんです
私たちはえらいそれに執着しているんですね
ただこの肉体に だから人間何に執着する
まず肉体に執着している
それでこの肉体は現れては消えていく
現れ ずっとそういうことでしょう
ずっと変化して変化して
一瞬でも止まってるわけじゃないんです
それ見てみなさいと 体は今の 1秒の体は
次の 1秒の体とは違うんです
ずっと変化していくでしょうと
それ見てみなさいと そうすると執着するのは愚らしくなってくるんですよ
今がもう自分の体がもうすぐ変わっちゃいますよと
そこをわかると 瞬間瞬間変化していくんだとわかったら
もう執着するのなんだアホやと自分でなって執着が消えちゃうんです
1番目はルーパであって
肉体の体  2番目はヴェーダナーですね
体で感じること 楽しいとか苦しいとかね
で この感覚ですね  2番目は
で  3番目は心の まあから全部心ですけど
体で感じたりするんだけど
結局心で感じますけどね
サンカーラ サンカーラっていうのは
この まあどうもじっとしていられない
あれやりたい これやりたいという何かが衝動があるんですね
いつでも見たい 聞きたい
喋りたい 歩きたい 座りたいとか寝たいとかね
ずっと我々は心の中でこの何か衝動的なエネルギー持ってるんですね
ではそれ観察してみてくださいと
ずっと変化するんですよ
歩きたいと思ったって
また他の衝動が割り込んじゃったら
まあいい やめたということになっちゃうと
寝たいなと思った衝動を持たなくても
何か他の出来事ったら
じゃあこれやりますと
もう寝るつもりはもうないということになっちゃうしね
だからもうそれそれまたあんまり長持ちしない
ものすごく変わるんですね
もう自分が だから人にあんた何やりたいかと聞いたって
もう答えがないでしょ
何かやりたいんだけど
もうもうはっきりしない
あれもこれもやりたいんですね
ですから この目で見たいと
耳で聞きたいとかね 舌で味わいたいとかね
体でもいろんなことをしたいとね
脳で考えたいとかね そうやっていろいろこの体がいっぱいあるんですね
それはサンカーラですね
サーンニャーが抜けちゃった
まあサーンニャーっていうのは
私は私の解釈はまあただ概念やと
勉強したものやらね まあ全ての概念の塊やと思った方が分かりやすい
頭の中にいっぱい溜まっているあらゆる概念
それまた変化するでしょ
それに執着してるでしょ
私はこれは勉強してる
あれは勉強してるとかね
これを知ってる あれを知ってるとかね
だからまず仏教はに興味ないのは
これ概念の問題でしょ
世の中にあるもう正真正銘の間違ってるくだらない概念にえらい執着を感じて
もう事実語るとすごく嫌になるんですね
ですから この概念も人間のもう執着の元になっている
次にサンカーラ まあ 5番目はヴィンニャー
心ですね 認識そのものですね
それをこの あ このように生まれた
このように消えていったと観察しなさい
イティルーパン これがルーパであると
この肉体がルーパである
イティルーパッサムダヨ
この肉体がこのように現れてくるんだよと
例えばご飯を食べた このご飯がこれからこの肉体になるんだぞとかね
見たらもうご飯と肉体えらい違うもんなんですけどね
でも一旦体に入って体の一部になってしまうし
それでそのまままた消えていくでしょ
食べたものはいろんなエネルギーの形で消えちゃうと
また物質を入れなくちゃいけない
そうやってそれぐらい見たっても十分でしょうしね
ああやって体が変わるんだ
変わるんだと と見る サムドヨ イティ ルーパッサ アッタガモ
このようにルーパが消えていくんだと
それからヴェーダナーについては
ヴェーダナーがこういうふうに生まれるんだと
どういうふうにヴェーダナーが生まれるとか
ものを触れるとヴェーダナーが生まれるんですよ
目に形が飛び出して飛んでくると
ヴェーダナーがフィーリングが生まれる
耳に音が飛び出してくると
そちらにヴェーダナーが生まれてくる
体にいろんなものをぶつかると
ヴェーダナーという感覚が生まれてくる
鼻に香りがぶつかると
嗅ぐという感覚が生まれてくる
こういうふうに生まれるんだ
こういうふうに消えるんだと観察すると
サンカーラの場合も同じ観察する
みんなの場合もそういうふうに観察してみると
そのように観察していると
ある日一つ消えてしまいます
アスミマナ 私 私という気持ちが消えちゃう
私 私というのは この五蘊にみんな馬鹿だから私
私と言うんですよ 私がいるんだ
自我があるんだ 魂があるんだとかね
よく客観的に分析すると
この五つしか見つからないんですよ
だから この我論に逆らうために
わざとこの執着という尺度でお釈迦様は分類したんです
我は執着の大本だから
魂は永遠なりと 死んでも死なないんだと
というふうに思っているでしょうに
人の価値は魂にあるんだと
なんで動物殺したってもいいのに
人は殺してはいけないかと
人間には魂があるんだからと
動物にはないんだと 言うでしょう
自分に魂あるんだからあるかどうかもわからない人々が
動物の魂がないんだからもう殺したい放題牛を殺して豚を殺して魚を殺して動物を殺して食べているんですね
楽しみにも殺したりするしね
とにかく執着の種はもう我ですね
魂ですね だからお釈迦様は執着という尺度で体を分析してみる
魂あるなら見つかるんですからね
別に執着するものは五つしか見つからないんですね
色受想行識しか見つからないんです
それには執着しています
我は存在しない 人間の誤解
錯覚 なぜその錯覚が生まれるかというと
この生まれて消えるのではないかと
それを分かってないんですね
生まれて消えるんでしょうと
だったら我がないんだと
その単純なことをわからない
ですから この五蘊に対して
この生まれて消えるんだ
生まれて消えるんだ 生まれて消えるんだ
生まれて消える これを観察してみなさい
そうするとアスミマナ
私がいるんだというこのマナが
この我慢が消えてしまう
これ我見もあるし 我慢ってもあるしね
アスミマナ 自我がないんだとわかったら
それ悟りなんですよ だからそれは何かといえば
自分がどれくらいまだ煩悩も残っているかということで
まだまだ欲とかあるんだったら
もう預流果なんです 同時に欲も嫌いさっぱり全て消えちゃったならば
もう阿羅漢果なんです
だからそれはもう俗人に素人にわかることじゃないんです
アスミマナが消えたんだ
だからあなた阿羅漢果あるいは完全に悟っているのか
それまた本人は決めるんです
観察して だから厳密な正直な世界だからね
そちらはインチキはない
厳密な正直な世界だから
人に絶対言わないのはそういうわけなんだ
言おうとしちゃうと もう正直っていうことは消えちゃうと
だから聞いた人もひどい目に遭う
そんな聞いてどう踏ん張っても
人間の知識をどう絞って聞いても答えが返ってこないんです
それより仏教の方がかなり上だからね
だからでも聞く方はあります
仏教の世界を理解して
それなりの心構えで それなりの知識能力ある人が聞くと淡々と言ってあげます
だから決して秘密でもないし
人々の中では とにかくアスミマナ消えると
私がいるんだということは
この五蘊は生滅転換するんだということを分かったら消えてしまう
アスミマナと同時にもう欲も怒りもあらゆるものが消えちゃったら
もう完全悟りでアスミマナだけ消えてしまえば預流果ということでね
イティタッタ サンパジャーナホテ
アスミマナ消えたんだということをその人は確認する
イメーコーテーアーナンダダンマーエーカントクサラヤティカ
この教えは 今まで教えたこの方法は
今いくつか教えたんですよ
ヴィパッサナーの世界に入って
これはエーカント absolutely
絶対的にクサラアイカ
クサラ 善だよと これだけは絶対的に何の混じりっけもない
絶対的な善の道やということ
クサラ アイエティカ 善の世界だと
善 あの 善悪の善ですね
あるいは 聖なる世界 絶対的に聖なる
優れてる世界 ロークったら
絶対的なもう出世間的
世の中と関係ない世界
アナヴァッカンタパーピマタ
アナヴァッカンタっていうのは堕落することなんですけど
日本語はどうなってますか
悪きもの化する 善なる出世間のもので
悪きものを与えるところのないもの
うん いわゆるパーピマタ
あの悪い考え方 あるいは俗世間の考え方を持ってる人々にはもう立ち入りできる世界ではありませんと
今まで説明した世界は
で そこで終了いたします
この五蘊の観察も一つのヴィパッサナーの瞑想です
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝けし
開運の慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱なれられますように
では どうもありがとうございました
遅く始まって早く終わっちゃった
[笑い] 五 四本